[Music]
so as more and more vaccine mandates are
being enforced by companies unvaccinated
employees who have been terminated are
suing for wrongful dismissal this is a
growing issue as businesses are caught
in between ensuring a safe workplace and
potentially facing lawsuits for
requiring vaccinations for more on this
employment lawyer leor samfiro joins us
to break down your workers rights lior
always great to see you an incredibly
important topic let's get into the
details here what constitutes
a wrongful dismissal how prevalent are
these claims from your point of view
so anthony despite what the name
wrongful dismissal suggests a wrongful
dismissal doesn't have much to do with
the reason someone is let go really
along for this missile is a situation
where an employee is let go either
without severance or with insufficient
severance so it all comes down to that
severance if you've been let go even if
the reason is amazingly fine if you
haven't been paid proper severance
you've been wrongfully dismissed now
even pre-covert 19 pre-pandemic most
individuals when they were let go even
if they've been offered severance i
always found there were mo more
severance so it was a wrongful dismissal
but anthony i can tell you that over the
last six months with the number of
people being let go because of their
vaccine status in my 20 years of
practice i have not seen this many
wrongful dismissal cases in such a short
period of time so our courts are going
to be quite busy over the next number of
months that's remarkable now how
difficult effectively are these claims
to prove to resolve uh give us a sense
of how long it takes and i wonder the
likelihood of success from your
perspective as well
so i know that there's always a bad
connotation with respect to legal
proceedings people always believe oh my
gosh it's going to take years and that
may be true for some cases criminal
cases personal injury cases that is not
the case with respect to employment law
cases employment law cases on the whole
resolve fairly quickly and the timeline
is often measured in weeks not months 98
99 of them are going to resolve weak
months before they even go to a
courtroom so you don't have to look at
it in that sense
matters resolve usually fairly quickly
and i do think for the reasons that
we've discussed in the past the fact
that there's no government mandates for
most individuals that have been
wrongfully dismissed because of their
vaccine status yes there's a very good
and high likelihood of being successful
so once this happens if an employee
loses his or her job
are they allowed to work in the meantime
what are the rules on that
certainly we understand that individuals
have
the right to have the need to find
employment to earn a living so not only
are employees that have been wrongfully
dismissed allowed to work somewhere else
they have the legal obligation to look
for another job we call that the duty to
mitigate you have a duty if you've been
let go to try to replace the income that
you've lost by looking and trying to
find another job so that's absolutely
fine i do think though anthony that
individuals that have lost their job
because of their vaccine status are
going to find a heart have a hard time
finding another job because they may not
be hired because they're not vaccinated
that's an important point as well so
let's get to the court ruling or the
judge's ruling in this
and this kind of goes both ways doesn't
it for the employee and the employer how
does it impact cases going forward
so in canada we have a precedent system
in other words a lot of our laws have
been created
by judges and whatever judges decide
often set precedent for other future
cases now with respect to vaccine cases
there have been no court cases yet on
this issue i don't expect any before the
summer or the or the fall of 2022 and
honestly by then many if not most cases
would have resolved so yes we will have
some court decisions coming up in uh at
some point this year
and they may set precedent for other
cases
those cases sometimes can be
differentiated or distinguished so it's
not necessarily a final ruling but as i
said before 98 99 of these cases the the
vast cases that we're seeing right now
will actually resolve before a judge
ever has an opportunity to consider and
to rule on it
important issues but you are seeing i
mean we're talking about dozens of cases
hundreds of cases not just for you but
employment lawyers across the country is
that what we're seeing
well i can tell you that my firm alone
we're just one firm we're handling a few
hundred of these across canada so as a
whole there's certainly thousands of
these cases ongoing right now as i said
in 20 years i've never seen anything
quite so substantial so i think that
there's a lot of more information on
this and news and even court decisions
to come look there are many angles to
this important story and this is one in
incredibly important perspective as well
we appreciate this employment lawyer
leor semfier always great to see you
have a great weekend sir